rick just finished eating with his
family at a restaurant the total bill
from for his family was 52
and rick was pretty impressed with the
service so he's going to leave a 25
tip
he wants to know the total amount the
total amount
he should leave at the table
select the equations rick can use and
determine the total bill including the
tip so the unknown thing the thing that
we should figure out is the total amount
he should leave at the table so let's
just call that
let's just call that x
now there's a couple of ways we could
think about it we could think about it
as the ratio between the total amount
he's going to pay
and the actual bill the ratio between
the total amount he's going to pay and
the actual bill
that should be the same thing as the
ratio between the respective ratios so
you could view the actual amount the
actual amount of the bill as being 100
percent that is a hundred percent of the
bill but he doesn't want to just pay a
hundred percent he wants to pay a
hundred percent
plus a 25
tip
plus 25
tip so we could rewrite everything that
i just did here as
x over 52
is equal to a hundred percent plus 25
percent i could write that as 125
over 100
over
100 percent now if we look at the
choices here this looks exactly like
this if we just swap the left and right
hand side we get 125 over 100 is equal
to x over 52. so we can select this one
and once again this makes sense the
ratio between what he's going to pay
with the tip to 100
or the percentage that he's going to pay
if you include the tip
relative to 100 is going to be the
actual amount he pays relative to the
actual bill now let's see if any of
these other ones make sense over here
so here he says it's the ratio of the
actual bill to 100
is equal to the ratio you're going to
pay 125
now this makes sense too let me just
rewrite it again for emphasis so here
they're constructing a proportion where
you have the ratio of the total bill and
you're saying hey look that total bill
is a hundred percent
is a hundred percent and we want to find
actually let me write that in blue
the total bill is 100
and we want to see
this ratio should be the same as the
ratio between the actual amount we're
paying and 125 and 125
so you increased this by 25 percent
well you're going to have to increase
you're going to have to increase this by
25 as well to get the actual amount that
you're paying
so this makes sense as well
now what about this the ratio between
100 and 125
should be equal to x over 52.
now this
does not make sense because this is the
ratio between kind of the full price
without paying the tip and the tip well
here is the tip and the full price so if
you swapped these two if you wrote this
as 52 over x then you could check this
but here you're not finding the ratio
between the corresponding things so i
would not check this one there but
either way our last thing to do is
actually to figure out how much tip rick
should leave so we need to actually
solve for x and we could go back to this
original equation here and if we
multiply both sides by 52
both sides by 52 we get x
x is equal to
125 divided by 100 percent is 1.25
1.25
times 52
times
and then i can just multiply that let's
see 52
4 goes into 52 13 times so this is going
to be one point well actually let me
just divide i don't know let me just let
me just multiply that out i don't want
to make a mistake here so 1.25
times 52
times
2 times 5 is ten
two times two is four plus one is five
two times one is two let's throw zero
down here because we're now multiplying
by fifty
five times five is twenty-five
five times 2 is 10 plus 2 is 12.
5 times 1 is 5 plus 1 is 6. so we get 0
let's carry that 1 we get a 5 we get a 6
and we have 2 numbers behind the decimal
point it is 65 and that's right that's
plus a third plus a fourth of 52 which
is 13 52 plus 13 is 65.
so he should leave 65 dollars
if we want to include
the tip